so first of all I'd like to thank chain
react for having me here and putting up
this awesome show and I'm just enjoying
myself as much as you guys are
and it's been unbelievably awesome great
job all speakers great job infinite
reges love it love being here
so I'm gonna be talking about the ten
lessons that I've learned building react
native apps the funny story here is I
think Jason the panel host from a few
years ago had a sneak peek with my
slides and he probably took some
pointers so a lot of this has already
talked about a little bit so
nevertheless is perfect time to have a
recap because most of us have had the
same ten lessons I guess all right so
I'm gonna be touching on a lot of those
points I'm at the theory of each hundred
and I'm a senior software engineer
working for a healthcare start-up in
Kansas City called read Eva's health and
what's cool about us there is we built
critical healthcare scenarios on the
mobile platform both iOS and Android so
we take care of things like stroke
sepsis cardiac arrest and so on and it's
all entirely built and react native and
that's how I am a react native developer
and Here I am I'm gonna start with the
first lesson learned react now some of
you here are gonna get pretty annoyed by
this lesson and be like do obviously I'm
gonna learn react but I didn't so these
are the ten lessons I learned a hard way
so I'm sure there's somebody here who is
gonna get started with react native
before realizing that they need to learn
react so long story short when I started
working on react native I was from a
completely different background I was
doing Java and C++ and then I got to
work for the startup here and I was
asked code react native so I had no idea
what I was getting into I did not know
JavaScript and I did not know react and
I was just gonna start coding react
native
so that's not possible so please learn
react if you haven't learned react the
things that you really need to learn
about are what is a props what our state
lifecycle methods and the composition
model of react and with react native you
also need to know JSX which is kind of
optional in react but that's how you
code and react native the endpoint is
basically thinking react and my advice
would also be maybe caught a couple apps
in react and familiarize yourself with
react because react native is
essentially JavaScript and react so
learn that first and don't be like me
and jump in before you learn react
listen to talked about quite a bit in
the last two days navigation navigation
is still evolving I started coding react
native in 2016 and at that time it was
very very difficult to understand what
was going on what was the library I
needed to pick and for those of you who
are wondering what is this navigation we
are talking about it's basically the
transition transition between the
screens on your mobile app right it's
the routing for your mobile app there
are so many screens you're gonna have
even for a simple application you press
the home button you go to the back
button and tons of screens and
navigation is really a very crucial
piece of your application and picking
the right library is super important and
you may end up seeing all of these
options and don't get worried because
there are some cool options that you can
solidify to don't don't freak out here
are some of the libraries I've used
which are kind of irrelevant right now
but I still would like to mention kind
of the journey I use something called
navigation experimental long ago and it
was an experimental library and got
deprecated so that's no go and then I
use something called navigator gone
there was navigation iOS it was only for
iOS so don't use it then there was
native navigation which was I think by
Airbnb and they stopped support for that
that's gone and then there was react
navigation so this is where we ended up
finally and we are using react
navigation and I guess it's in version
3.0 now and it's super cool and we
really enjoyed using react navigation
and a tip would be if you'd like react
navigation you can also use a react
native route of flux along with it it's
kind of a wrapper
it's a wrapper around react navigation
and I've enjoyed using that because the
API is just so much easier and even if
things were gonna change and react
navigation when react native route of
flux upgrades they're gonna take care of
it so I've enjoyed using react
navigation in combination with react
native route of flux I should have added
that on my slide and if you're someone
who really wants a complete native
navigation on both your iOS and Android
you can go for react native navigation
I've heard a lot of cool things about it
but I have not used it I probably want
to try that on a different project
outside of my work but you have two
solid options react navigation or react
native navigation and just forget about
the past and all the other you know
stack overflow questions about
navigation and don't get confused and
that's the lesson about navigation the
next lesson was also talked by the panel
quite a bit about stake management well
in my experience I I do enjoy using
external state management libraries like
redux and mob X and the reason we use
that is when you complicated your apps
become very complicated so when we
started coding our app it was just a
prototype and then it grew and grew and
grew and then we started passing all the
props down to the children and it kept
growing and got complex to handle and
that's when libraries like redux and mob
x come in place now we don't want a
battle between redux and mob x because
they're both trying to solve the same
problem and as somebody else mentioned
in the panel it's really up about the
developer whatever you like you can pick
one of them redux does come with a lot
of
the plate and mob X is kind of easier to
pick up for a newbie it has less of a
learning curve but Redux again has a lot
of these community support awesome
developer tools and things like that so
we chose to pick Redux for our
application and mob X also is awesome so
it's just really up to you
and of course with the advent of Apollo
and things like that there are other
options for you to take care of your
state management as well but do you
always need state management what are
the signs that you really need state
management like they talked about if you
have a lot of props passed through a
hierarchy of components it's probably a
good time to consider state management
libraries you don't want to keep passing
props down parent to child to child to
trial to trial if you have global
components let's say you have
notifications that is a good time to use
a external state management library as
well also for instance you have user
information like for example in our app
we have patient info that we show across
multiple container components maybe
that's a good one for you to use Redux
or mob X or you can use react hooks
maybe I haven't dived too much into
react hooks but with the combination of
contexts and react talks maybe you can
do away with state management libraries
as well so whatever your choice is think
about it if you're picking a library
just play with it a little bit and
decide which one would scale for your
application all right another question
from the panel again should I use
explore or not I'm a big fan of Expo as
well and Expo is awesome it lets you
build react native apps super fast so if
you're building a rapid prototype or if
you're building an app that needs to go
real quick Expo is the way to go even in
your react native official documentation
you'll notice that they have two ways of
doing react native you can either use
the react native CLI or you use the
expose CLI so it's just up to you some
points to think about whether you want
to use Expo or not if you hate
the build configuration that you have to
deal with go for Expo you don't have to
deal with any of that and you use just
JavaScript if you're someone who doesn't
want to touch native code you just want
a code you know JavaScript react native
go for expo you won't even have access
to the native code so you're not gonna
touch that no Xcode no Android studio
life is just easy with expo and you can
also publish over-the-air updates
anytime and it is super awesome but
there are times when you may have to say
no to expose wall export could be
restrictive sometimes so it's good to
know somebody mentioned that Expo has a
list of things that you want to know
before you use Expo and when to say no
to Expo so it is restrictive sometimes
in the sense like let's say you want to
use a push notification service of your
choice you can't do that with Expo so if
you have things like that you may want
to think about whether expose the right
fit for your product and it is kind of
loaded with API is that you may or may
not use that's just the way it comes out
it's kind of like a framework so it may
not be suitable if you have a super lean
app if that's your aim maybe it may not
work out and also they are working on it
and we've talked about it in the panel
as well not all iOS and Android api's
are available today but they're doing a
lot of work towards that so that's
something to consider as well so if you
want access to a native feature like
bluetooth I don't think Expo has support
for that yet and maybe it'll come in the
future so before you choose to use expo
or not just kind of get your
requirements nailed down and know what
your app really needs like what are the
native features and things that you need
to use to make that judgment and again
the same thing where you can't change
the native code if that's something you
really want to do maybe expose not
something you can pick and of course you
can detach your app from expo anytime
but again it comes with the cost where
you may have to plan for some kind of
additional coding so maybe the
navigation changes maybe the push
notification changes but you need to
plan for that over
you have your choice you have Expo with
Expo react native app or an app without
Expo so it just really depends on your
use case and your requirements what are
the native features you need and things
like that so think about it before you
say no or yes to Expo all right
the next lesson is my favorite
please don't postpone testing your
Android devices this is these two
characters who are battling and they're
wondering nope iOS nope Android nope iOS
but remember you're building a
cross-platform application for both iOS
and Android that is why you pick react
native if not you would be a iOS
developer or an Android developer so
keep that in mind and quit battling from
from the experience I have areas where I
actually notice problems is that most of
the developers that I work with and in
my team somehow have iOS devices
including me and then what happens is we
have our own personal device and we like
to test on that because it's just easier
you can deploy it test it and you don't
have to deal with other devices so that
is a problem because if you mostly have
iOS you're gonna forget about Android
another problem is that developers
usually run only one emulator at a time
now the reason for that is also because
the Android emulators for some reason
are really slow and I even hear noises
from my laptop when I open up Android
studio and that is true I don't know why
it's just it's just like that and then
what happens is it kind of reduces the
developer velocity so we're like a
closed Android studio close that
emulator just open the iOS emulator it
runs smooth and fine it's okay the
mistake is then you're assuming that it
works on Android as well so don't do
that a tip for that would be you know
what we do is we kind of rotate get your
developers to sign up and say ok
developer a this week you're gonna use
an android emulator developer be this
week you're gonna use
the iOS emulator and then by the time
the week is over just rotate them that
way they don't feel bad and keep doing
that so that way you can catch your bugs
early on during development time at just
that stage before you even like go and
deploy to the devices I think some
people touch this point many third-party
libraries really don't support Android
as well and that also is because of the
same reason that the overall react
native experience for some reason it's
just kind of better with iOS so we need
to change that at at the developer level
as well and that's gonna change the
third-party libraries as well because
the people coding those libraries are
doing the same mistakes so we want to
make sure that we kind of treat Android
and iOS as equals and test Android
devices along with your iOS devices so
some tips one thing that really helped
us is to automate both our iOS and
Android releases in the beginning we
just automated the iOS deployments but
then we just didn't care to automate or
Android releases so what then happened
was we sent emails to our testers within
the team to just download and install
the android apk and that was an
extremely frustrating experience to
everybody and they just quit testing
Android so don't be that person spend
some time and figure out how to automate
both iOS and Android that way the
testers feel feel nice to test Android
as well as well sorry and also maximize
your device's get your company or your
team to buy as many devices as they can
to test especially for Android because
there's just so many devices that behave
so differently when you test the code
for instance the newer Android devices
require more explicit permissions let's
say you want to access the photo gallery
it works well with the older devices but
then when you go and try this out on a
newer device you're like oh I have to go
update my build out Gradle settings to
give some more permissions so these are
things you encounter only when you try
testing on different devices if
you would never discover those problems
so maximize the devices and obviously
test early and often test at the
development stage test at beta testing
stages so just make sure you keep
testing both the devices equally as
often as you can
and as we talked about assigned
developers in rotation even if they
don't like it you can rotate them later
on so that way you catch bugs during the
development stage bottom line is treat
them as equals as much as possible that
way you give your user and native
experience on both iOS and Android and
everybody loves your app not just iOS
users alright as we're talking about
testing the next lesson we learned is on
testing I really like this quote by
Henry Ford on quality means doing it
right even when no one is looking this
is something that really rings a bell to
me about software testing as well
because we as software developers
sometimes are overconfident we're
overconfident about when we can finish
the project and how cool our code is so
we may say hey it's gonna take me two
days to finish this but then it's
actually going to take two weeks because
you didn't account for testing you're in
account for code reviews you just talked
about your coding and you forgot about
everything else and that's okay but the
other problem that software developers
are notorious for is also being
overconfident about the code but that
that's not good you need to test your
code and make sure it works before you
are confident about it so for react
native unit testing we use gest which is
super cool and based on the state of
JavaScript survey from 2018 it ranks as
number one among testing frameworks for
JavaScript followed by mocha jasmine and
so many other cool frameworks so make
sure you write good unit test which is
like the basic level of testing that you
need to do for your code before you ship
it and we've had a great experience
writing justice for our react native
projects how many of you used just here
for react native awesome everybody
almost great cool the next thing that
I'd like to touch is
to entus we recently started doing that
for our react native app and we use
something called detox so detox
basically tests your mobile app while
it's running on either a real device or
an emulator and it interacts with it
just like a real user so it is super
awesome and how many of you use detox
quite a few okay so detox is really cool
and I highly recommend trying that out
what it really does is it emulates a
user testing experience for you and it's
very similar to you know these
end-to-end tests that you see for the
web it it's super awesome because it is
built specially for mobile and react
native and it works really well and
detox is not really a black box test
they call themselves as a gray box test
what it does is it allows to test the
framework from within the app so they
monitor the app from inside and actually
synchronize with it so this way it's not
super flaky and you know you can
actually trust the detox test to do a
good job and what does it do for your
team it saves you tons of time
it helps automate a complete manual QA
process and it saves developers testers
and everybody else a lot of time I've
noticed that it's best if specifically
with detox tests like everybody who's
non-technical loves it on our team
because they can actually see this
happening right in front of the eyes it
goes super fast and it emulates as I
said the user testing experience and
that is great for you know people who
are non texting technical to just look
at it and be like oh wow it can do that
that would take me hours to do and also
it's super simple to write and execute
it's all written in JavaScript so please
do check it out for your integration
tests basically testing makes your ship
code with a lot of confidence if you
haven't been writing tests this is a
good time to write write tests and you
can explore several different options
outside of just and detox and you know
basically make sure that your code is
foolproof alright so as we talk about
testing and then the next step is
continuous delivery
so for continuous delivery we use a tool
called Fastlane how many of you use
Fastlane a lot of people are awesome so
maybe like 50% uses Fastlane cool
I love Fastlane what it does for me is
it can distribute beta bills and that is
awesome because I can then add as many
tests as I want and they can test my
beta versions and it can also do some of
the more monotonous tasks like capture
screenshots code signing and app store
deployment so these are things that
developers kind of hate to do and
Fastlane takes a little bit of burden
outside of that from you and good news
is it's cross-platform it can do both
iOS and Android and tons of our safes so
I highly recommend checking out Fastlane
for your continuous delivery and using
Fastlane we do our beta deployments so
frequently even like everyday or
multiple times a day
and for iOS we use a test flight test
flight is basically an app which can
have your beta deployments for iOS it
will have your version numbers for your
beta version and it can have like
release notes and things like that so it
is basically almost like an app store
experience but you just develop you just
install a better app and the other one
we use for Android is Google Play and we
also use crashlytics sometimes so the
thing about Google Play is that
sometimes for testers it could get
confusing are they downloading the prod
app or the beta app so if that kind of
confusion needs to be eliminated you can
use crashlytics as an alternative to
deploy or beta for Android and it is
also a product by Google so it really
doesn't make a difference for that so
I've had a good experience with
crashlytics because it also shows me
crash reports you can also check out
like how the users are using your app
and user retention and other analytics
in addition to just using it for
installing your beta apps so check those
out for beta deployments that does
anyone use crashlytics here okay cool so
yep definitely check that out for
deploying your better app all right the
next lesson is picking the right library
we had a whole talk about open source
and a community in react native and it
is sometimes challenging to pick the
right library so there are several times
you may encounter that hey I don't think
this is available out of the box there
are these components don't exist so how
do you really pick the right library the
strategy we use is very basic look at
github see the number of contributors
look at how active the community is
around that library and of course some
community some libraries are awesome but
they don't have a lot of lot going on so
if you find libraries like that you can
fork it or be a contributor to it you
know so it really depends on what you're
looking for there is this react Native
community which has about 70
repositories today and it is awesome it
is vetted by the leaders of react native
and it has all almost I think 50 or 60
contributors I can't remember the exact
number but it is super awesome the
solutions for like camera if you want to
sound video and many other native
components that don't exist out of the
box are available in react native
community and again if you do happen to
call your own component if you're
creating solutions today that don't
exist try to open-source them and tweet
about it and you know just talk about it
a little bit in the community so people
are aware of it and it becomes a part of
the react Native community we just want
to help each other out here and that's
that's kind of what you need to do when
you're picking the right library the
next lesson is upgrades have been hard
in react native and everybody who's
working on react native knows that and
obviously that's also because it's
rapidly changing and things things are
going so fast it's got a it's got a big
get better after a few months or few
years but until then we need to work
with what we have so some tips before
you upgrade make sure you plan for it
don't
why to do upgrades just when you feel
like it or before a prod release and
things like that always make sure your
upgrades are planned well and you have
enough padding time to upgrade
in my experience upgrades have lasted a
few hours to a few weeks yes and that's
because sometimes you know a library
you've used may have gotten deprecated
for example the navigation experimental
library I use God replicated and I had
to rewrite all of that so just plan
ahead of time and the most important
thing is upgrade often if you're going
to wait for six to seven months to
upgrade you're gonna be having a tough
time because react native changes so
rapidly and you don't want to you know
wait for too long before you upgrade so
keep up with the latest react native
releases just just wait for a little bit
make sure everything's stable and go
ahead and upgrade so we try to keep our
app as upgraded as possible and redo it
as often as possible so we don't run
into as many issues as we used to a few
years ago because we just waited to
upgrade it was just harder back then and
react native official documentation has
steps for upgrading so you can check
that link out which takes you in the
right direction towards upgrading
finally about performance obviously last
but not the least performance is super
important for your mobile application
and that's I would say I would say it's
more important for a mobile app to
perform better than even a website
because this is something you put on
people's phones and if your application
is gonna be lagging doesn't perform well
the users are gonna hate it and they're
gonna uninstall it so keep in mind that
performance is really important and
today we had ROM talk about performance
and the he gave a full talk about it so
if you didn't see it definitely go check
it out on YouTube when it's live some
tips on performance from what we've done
in the past
if you've using animations make sure
that you use the prop use native driver
and set that to true that makes a huge
difference it's gonna make sure that
your animations are running on the need
driver instead of the JavaScript side
and we noticed that our animations were
lagging and wasn't going as well
especially on Android and then we
realized hey we could just use this prop
and set that to true and it made a whole
lot of difference so a simple thing like
that really makes a difference because
it's gonna run on the native side so
keep that in mind and also that prop
doesn't really work out for layouts so
if you're using flexbox and position
properties it's not gonna work out but
for the most part your animations can be
switched to the native driver if you're
using a larger list let's say you are
having an app like Instagram with a lot
of pictures that you need to load make
sure you use the recent components which
is flat list or section lists for larger
lists they perform really well in
comparison to some of the older
components like ListView the reason I'm
saying this is when you like look into
Stack Overflow or other places some of
the code snippets you may come across
are older so make sure you don't use
ListView just go for flat list or
section lists and if you're using a list
make sure that every item in the list
has a key and this is this is applicable
to react as well and the reason we need
to do that is if you don't have a unique
key for every list item reactor's gonna
keep read rendering every time you add
or remove an item so make sure you have
an unique key and this makes a
significant difference in performance
also if you're using react class
components make sure that you bind early
and render simple what we mean by that
is your bindings need to happen at the
constructor level or early on and your
render methods just need to look simple
I don't know if you can see that and the
wrong way to do that is to do the
binding inside the render method so
that's not how we want to do it and
there are so many other tips obviously
performance is a huge aspect and you can
also take a look at the official react
native Doc's talks a lot about
performance and different ways to like
profile and things like that
so keep in mind your performance of your
app is super important all right
we reached the end of the lessons and
I'm just gonna recap all of them so it
stays fresh learn react please
navigation is at a much better spot
today although it's still evolving
either go for react navigation or react
native navigation and new state
management based on your likes and needs
if necessary if you have a complex
application explore not expose great but
does it fit your use case you have to
you have to decide that
don't treat Android you know like a bad
person it's it's cool people be happy if
you test it early on and testing write
unit tests write integration tests or as
many tests as you can to make your app
super solid continuous delivery use fast
lane I really like it
and picking the right library pick the
right library and also contribute as
much as you can to the community which
is growing and upgrade often so you
don't complain as much about upgrades
and focus on performance so that's a
recap and it's a super cool time to be a
react native developer things are going
so great in the community it's awesome
and you can see that with all the
enthusiasm that's happening at chain
react right here I'm really honored to
be here thank you so much Shane react
for having me and if you have any
questions you I'm here or you can even
tweet me whatever thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]